[Music]  you're taking a first look at the new  meeting and convention space opening at  circa resorts and casino today the  downtown resort unveiled its 35 thousand  square foot event facility featuring 13  meeting rooms with walls that can expand  for additional spacing is now the second  phase in the property's new developments  and the one thing we really wanted to do  is um you know in working through this  we worked with the lvcva we really  wanted to focus in on technology so we  think we're bringing some of the highest  tech meeting space to las vegas  the resort will officially launch the  space on september 1st however booking  for that space is available right now